nearly eight months
after this crisis
on the doorstep of two hundred thousand
american deaths
president trump has refused once again
to take responsibility
or to take action
folks the president's first
responsibility is to protect
the american people
and he won't
that's utterly disqualified
i trust vaccines
i trust scientists
but i don't trust donald trump
at this moment the american people can't
either
a vaccine would offer a way back to
normalcy and a path toward better days
for all of us
not only here but around the world
but it's not going to happen overnight
once we have it it's going to take
months to distribute it to the entire
population
the national science foundation is
coordinating with the cdc and other
agencies
they indicate that the first
group of people that should get the
vaccine if and when it is available
are people at the greatest risk
and that includes everything from
nursing homes to people with serious
pre-existing conditions that would cause
people to be in real trouble a lot of
those people happen to be black and
brown
happen to be black and brown
and so
it would be based upon the degree of
exposure would go first though
i would argue but i have a scientific
board laid out for me it would go first
as laid out for me today
to first responders doctors and nurses
the people who most we're most needed to
have available to deal with our crises
[Music]
so
okay
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to the winning brief show it is a
friday yo thursday welcome back to the
show
let me tell you something
ladies and gentlemen we are fully
staffed we are back
the vacation boy is vacationing
no more
welcome back brian smith
uh let me
bring to you miss leah blue eyes bella
hello share the show
and
mr woody the comedian mcadams what's up
man good morning good morning
let me say to you ladies and gentlemen i
went up when i was naming the show
i had to go back and i had to look at a
couple of things
uh we we saw yesterday that jinsaki
jinsaki was asked shouldn't biden bear
some of the blame
for people not wanting to get the
vaccine
because of what he said
in 2020. i really didn't put two and two
together until i saw some of the old
stuff and what he said
and let me
let me throw this out at you because
many of y'all are like wayne what are
you talking about
i'm gonna check this actually
i can't tell you his own words i can
only put it in his own words and let him
put it in his own words right now i
think it's going to be a very skeptical
american public about taking the vaccine
and they should be we can't trust the
president
and take his word and take a vaccine
that might cause harm to us if and when
the vaccine comes it's not likely to go
through all the tests that needs to be
ended trials that are needed to be done
let's just say there's a vaccine that is
approved and even distributed before the
election would you get it
well i think that's going to be an issue
for all of us when we finally do god
willing get a vaccine who's going to
take the shot
who's going to take the shot we will
need to have access
to the vaccine results so we can make
our independent assessment to make sure
that donald trump's fingerprints are not
on it you can be the first one to say
put me sign me up
they now say it's okay is the vaccine
safe
frankly i'm not going to trust the
federal government's opinion
and i wouldn't recommend to new yorkers
based on the federal government's
opinion and the question of whether it's
real when it's there that requires
enormous transparency would you trust
that vaccine there's very little that we
can trust that comes out of donald trump
as well we cannot take for granted this
process will be free of political
influence i don't trust the president
and i don't trust the fda if donald
trump can't give answers and
administration can't give answers to
these three questions the american
people should not have confidence you're
going to say to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly but trust
this federal administration and their
health administration that it's safe i
will say that i would not
trust donald trump how confident are you
in the approval process of the fda right
now how confident am i uh i'm not that
confident yes i would be hesitant but
i'm gonna ask a lot of questions you're
going to need someone other than this
fda
and this cdc saying it's safe you've got
to make all of it available to other
experts across the nation
so they can look and see
so there's consensus this is a safe
vaccine what i'm worried about is that
there's some sort of october surprise
and that there is a pressure put on the
decision makers here to announce the
vaccine in october of 2020. we're going
to put together our own group of doctors
and medical experts to review the
vaccine and the efficacy in the protocol
and if they say it's safe then i'll go
to the people of new york and i will say
it safe but if donald trump tells us i
should that we should take it i'm not
taking it
what changed y'all
i actually agree with for once i agree
with como
i don't trust the cdc and the fda i
agree with you
again
i i didn't vote for trump i i'm not a
trump supporter in any way
operation warp speed was a great was
great it worked it was very effective
and they were trying to throw dirt on
that they're trying to throw shade at it
before the election because you can't
say well he's doing a great job
with this but you should vote for me
anyhow
it shows you how much i care about the
safety of people go look at the polling
the polling data showed all the way up
till now
uh joe the biggest thing trump was hit
for was
his handling of the pandemic right like
that was like the big
push is he's mishandling this he's not
taking it seriously he's not doing
and you can't say that and also say his
plan to get the vaccine out there is
really good you can't say both those
things but imagine
democrats right now are blaming
republicans
on
misinformation
and also
on vaccines americans not wanting to
take the vaccine
and when
that two-minute two-minute plus
showed those democrat leaders they
weren't third tier or fourth tier they
weren't some guy sitting in a room
developing talking points they were
leaders
getting out here and saying i'm not
taking that vaccine as long as trump got
anything to do with it i ain't taking it
the only thing different from
uh the vaccine now is the vaccine still
came from trump
directly from trump
that's
the democrats yeah yeah it still pushed
through it was the same process the
things they complained about like it
won't have fda fda approval we're still
waiting for the fda approval again i've
heard i've heard september yeah we
should be we should be yeah they're
going to fast track it they need good
that means we can get therapeutic right
they need to clean up for the democrats
fast track that thing um i believe in
science i believe in science science
says
that our bodies our human bodies are
a miracle from god something created
them so whether you believe in god or
not these things were created and they
are miraculous they have the abilities
to do things that that the scientists
the claimed doctors can't get them to do
that
my body will fix itself my body if i
take care of it that's what i was saying
yesterday do good
you know uh
we don't want to political correctness
is wreck this whole damn thing because
nobody wants to say
if you're obese and you're sick and
you're addicted to drugs and food and
alcohol whatever
you get to covet you're screwed nobody
wants to say that three things a it
sucks that covet had to happen during an
election year it really does i wish it
would have happened
way after or way before
yeah i hear you number two
watching that video
makes me not want to take the vaccine
even more yeah say that they're gonna
trust the cdc in the fda and number
three
i want to defend something that i said
yesterday on twitter and a lot of people
took it the wrong way and it's like guys
you go you gotta you gotta do better
than that
finally fauci came out and said we need
a five day at home treatment to wreck
this covid
i've been saying that for two years not
because coven said not because the fauci
said it but because that's common sense
if you get a five-day at-home treatment
as soon as you test positive for covid
and you just have slight symptoms that
five-day treatment is gonna knock the
crap out of that covid and it's also
gonna stop it from mutating and you're
gonna not spread it to nine people
that is what we need and we can't get it
until these stupid vaccines are approved
so as soon as september comes you're
gonna start hearing falchi talk about we
need a five-day at-home treatment as
soon as he talks about it don't be
afraid of it because that was the point
the entire time they just had to rim rod
these ramrod as joe biden would say my
wife's got the back of a ramrod but we
had to ramrod these vaccines through
then we can get to the true thing which
is a five-day at-home treatment and then
this is going to just become an epidemic
zero hedge put up an article about
something that they're now finding uh
coming out of
jerusalem jerusalem post actually wrote
the original article saying they think
they have a five day yes and they're
ahead of the game they're like 20 years
ahead of us right and they're saying
that nobody will talk about this in
america
we have to get these vaccines approved
first look you need right right
you need everything for that you need
everything in your in your pouch you
know you mean you don't use just one
tool you don't use a hammer to fix
everything they're only using right now
you need to have you need to take every
tool that's available to you everyone
again that's natural immunity that's
vaccines and if we get a therapeutic
that's even better you know like vaccine
can prevent it if you do get it still
you get a therapeutic you know if you
spread it you get a therapeutic
hopefully the therapeutic could help cut
down on the actual spread of it it is
going to cut down on the variant
mutation yeah it's gonna cut you won't
see a mutation
oh they they're already saying that
there's uh or they jump from lambda uh
sorry delta it's a lambda now oh wait
till epson or epsilon absolutely feel
that one yeah they were i saw it on fake
news cnn something like that everything
yes oh the lambda it's the lambda
variant it's coming it's in peru
whatever omnicron that's going to be the
bad one
whatever but you know and um
here's another one of their dear leaders
uh who just resign
you know i
i just hope that they don't let him get
off for what he did to the nursing home
look whether a person died in a hospital
or died in a nursing home
it's
the people died
people died
i was in a hospital i got transferred to
a nursing home
and my father died my father was in a
nursing home got transferred to a
hospital my father died
people died
by the way
the same people are dying today
of the people who die
are
older people with comorbidities
happens to be the population that lives
in nursing homes
it's continuing today
even with all the testing that we're
doing
if you look at new york state
we
have a lower percentage of deaths in
nursing homes than other states
a third of all deaths in this nation are
from nursing homes
new york state we're only about 28
only but we're below the national
average in number of deaths in nursing
homes
but who cares 33 28 died in a hospital
died in a nursing home
they died
and
i dealt with the loss of my father
let me say some ladies and gentlemen
when
and
i don't know how many times i've said
this too but
if you've never been up on stage
woody
new comedian
you know something is working and you
know something ain't working yeah pretty
quickly
you know
when
you're okay i've lost him so i i gotta
get him i have to get him back somehow
now he didn't have a live audience
but he realized what he was saying was
stupid as hell he did i mean he realized
and for some reason
he didn't turn the corner he just kept
going down that
that road
where you know like the like the
presentation that he did didn't make
sense he wasn't making sense
right there he just kept going down the
road well people died go to the hospital
and get and and they didn't go to the
nursery
but then most people that all died in
their nursing home
but but then the nursing homes are built
to
to house the old people who die and
um
yeah and who cares
yeah
i have a seven and a three-year-old when
they do something wrong and they're
trying to tell you how they didn't do it
wrong that's him yeah right well you
know yeah that's him and then and then
yeah yeah right right yeah and what
you're talking about cuomo and you're
talking about the nursing homes and
you're talking about the deaths yeah um
yeah i don't know if anybody else has
seen it over the weekend the probably
the most banned
interview
was a nurse a woman named rose
uh david ikes i think interviewed her
and and it was shock she was
she was transferred from florida to new
york the epicenter of the covet thing
and she was so appalled and shocked as a
nurse by what was happening
she turned as an undercover
reporter to report the shockingness
of the deaths that were being caused on
purpose
by the mishandling and the insanity that
was coming out of new york
and there's there's emails
that show that they they knew about you
know here's the interest i was reading
today uh cuomo has
18 million dollars still in his campaign
finances he's limited to what he can do
with those campaign finances but one of
those things he can do is donate it to
other candidates
run a fake campaign and keep the money
but if you donate other candidates if
you have 18 million dollars to give
other people and you're going to be
investigated for something like this
i mean does 18 million dollars buy off
the attorney general sure does i mean
whenever he whenever i watched that
video just now it reminded me of when
ellen omar said some people did some
things on 9 11.
some people did some things you know
they got an airplane and you know in an
airplane people die people die in
airplanes and some people did something
you know i'm ted and
and i'm gonna bring this uh bring this
little
uh
comment back up uh for the first time in
history a variant is stronger than the
original virus right
and it's not they just want you to
believe that it is it's just more
contagious but it's not stronger but
let's just say let's just say that this
is true
then you go back to
[Music]
what china
probably meant to do in the first place
and how slow we are we are reacting
in a slow manner
to what
we saw it's almost it's almost like um
something happened last week in our
neighborhood
all of us live in the same neighborhood
uh
something happened in that neighborhood
and now we're reacting
to what happened last week however
we we are seeing
how
the devastating action
is affecting underground now it's
affecting us on the ground but we don't
see it because we're only
going of of what we saw on the top okay
that's what i've always believed about
this covert thing
they're treating what with what we saw
instead of treating
all the mutations and the mutations
in a way the mutations are getting
weaker and weaker
but they're spreading more quickly and
quickly or quicker and quicker right
like
that it's sooner or later
i think
i don't know maybe four or five and i'm
not gonna would and i'm not trying to
manifest nothing i'm i'm not
i'm just speculating
oh no man i just think there's a flip
switch on this thing i just think that
there's a flip switch that something's
going to happen in five or six years
from
because of the cocktails of all of these
uh
yeah
look at johnson and johnson for god's
sakes they couldn't even get baby powder
right i mean women were getting ovarian
cancer just from their baby powder
suntan lotion
when you're seeing all these uh you know
lawsuits groups class action lawsuits
you have to question the vaccine if you
don't question the vaccine there's
something wrong with you they just came
out with a study uh i can actually tell
you who the study is from so that way
nobody's thinking that i'm just making
it up but uh they came out with a study
saying that okay carnegie mellon
university and the university of
pittsburgh have found that the most
highly educated americans are the most
vaccine hesitant
the most highly educated americans are
the most vaccine hesitant
thanks for the compliment the most
highly educated people okay this is a
study that was done
by two bipartisan
all right there's a reason why the most
highly educated are leery on the vaccine
it's because it's been out for six
months i don't care rna by vaccines have
been studied for the last 20 years it's
never been put into a human being before
like this it took six months okay now
secondly
yes the virus is getting more contagious
which typical viruses do and then
they'll plateau off right
the only virus in history that was ever
more deadly was the diarrhea virus that
rabbits got in australia so that's why
we're not sure what's going to happen
with this virus yet yes there was a
virus in australia that hit the hit the
bunnies and they all got diarrhea and
really ill and they thought ah just let
it happen
uh you know it'll go it's talking about
a hot mess
yeah it'll be fine well it mutated worse
and it killed off the whole population
that's the only virus in history that's
ever gotten worse now if this was messed
with in a lab it definitely can get
worse then we might all
bleed out and die i don't know you just
have to accept it but right now we're
gonna see that this is more contagious
but it's not more deadly but you know
what's more dangerous than a more deadly
disease a more contagious disease
because that means more people in the
hospital that's why you're seeing more
people in the hospital because it's
affecting more people that technically
the first strain didn't so is it more
deadly no but it's just affecting more
people there you go and when you're
talking about gain of function
everything's out the window now they
literally used gain of function to
create a virus to kill off the rats in
australia and they programmed it to kill
just so many
they didn't want to kill them all they
just injected a few rats they gave it to
the second round they gave it to the
second round they gave it kind of like
network marketing you go find two
friends and you have those two friends
but they only wanted to go so many
levels deep and calculate the death rate
that's all they wanted so when it comes
to getting a function and fouchy and the
federal government telling fauci and his
crew
you can't do that in america and they're
like oh well crap we'll go to china and
do it then and they're like oh okay just
don't do it here yeah yeah that's i mean
that's one thing if you are worried
about a virus getting more deadly the
way it would get more deadly is if it
was programmed to do so
you know if it was if it was
broke down to the genomes and adjusted
so that as it mutated
uh you know and again that doesn't mean
it's done
purposely
but if you do that stuff in the lab
you haven't watched every movie out
there about a lab
they just literally confiscated three
ton of fentanyl and on the border that
came literally up through and started in
china
okay they gave us covet but everything's
okay oh that's just sanctioned china now
you know what i think we should do now
they run they run pretty much europe
is that what i think is that the final
solution legal that's the final
this would all be taken care of already
we'd all be living back in paradise here
in america
somebody's running for office
i might just do it now
it's like where's liam where's that key
where's that red button at well she's
i don't play games when you start
killing americans with fentanyl and
covid and you've got spies over here
it's bye-bye time you got to be a
vengeful somebody to to to try to get
america's young people
and killing them with fentanyl and then
like ain't strong enough
ten times the amount to kill yeah no no
you're absolutely true
this organization that i helped uh help
with and i'll actually i'll be out there
tonight helping them uh they they find
uh the drug drug addicts on the streets
and they help clean them up and turn
their lives around help them get their
kids back get their family back you know
just just really focus on god and help
them get back
to normal a lot of times though after
they get back they get this false sense
of identity that oh well i'm good to go
i'll be all right i don't need it
anymore
uh one guy matter of fact just recently
he said uh touch base with him and say
yeah yeah yeah i'm doing great yeah i'll
be back i just want to get my life
started moved away and uh yeah i like
the church and i haven't been a while
i'll be back
two weeks later we had his funeral
i'm telling you shit's hitting home that
fentanyl that drugs is out of it is
beyond
any kind of pandemic that we have ever
had and you know they stopped they they
don't call like i heard someone call
today a fentanyl murder instead of an
overdose and i think that's what it is
and you can blame it yeah yeah yeah yeah
well
they're lacing it in other drugs where
people don't know they're taking it i
mean that's the other side of that is
now you got drug addicts carrying their
own uh epipens yeah their own uh what is
it
yeah they got their own narcan i just
walk around with it in case i need it
again a lot of my friends are comics a
lot of my friends are comics so here's
that one in your skit i see i see a lot
of
i see a lot of stuff posted and i saw
someone posted that uh you need to start
carrying your own tester kits around for
your uh your cocaine and i was like oh
look at those people there like that's
your purity
because the fentanyl that's because
there was a there's a bunch of people
that dropped dead from fentanyl
overdoses from you know it's just like
it's everywhere they're putting it in
everything uh they're lacing uh
marijuana with it they're lacing you
know what i mean so it's like these
people who don't think they're drug
addicts become drug addicts and they
don't know they're taking a giant dose
and they take a giant dose and they die
but orange man bad but orange man bad
chinese good chinese chinese bcp good
somebody just say no just somebody oh
yeah i mean that's that's part of it but
you know somebody told me a lot of times
someone told me a lot well i was
watching the documentary and i i've
never taken drugs not even getting close
to it
but
i understood what the person was saying
the reason why they keep doing it is
because the first time they do it they
get taken to a place
that is so meg well in their words so
magnificent so so great you know
beautiful and stuff whatever
is that they want to get back to it and
they never can get back to it
and that's right
right but but the problem is you didn't
deserve that to begin with
every new high is a new low you don't
deserve to be that happy you don't
deserve to be that high you didn't do
anything to get that and that you got it
you got it outside of uh
normal society you got it outside of the
normal ways of getting things well
time to pay the piper because that ain't
free that nothing like that's free
you're gonna pay for it i once asked a
heroin addict
what it felt like and they said it was
like a warm blanket wrapped around you
and sunshine shining on you and you felt
no anxiety and you felt so so safe and
there was no fear it was such a euphoria
it's amazing that's how they explained
it to me and i said coming down's really
bad yeah and they said yeah it feels
like pure hell yeah that's that's scary
that's that's that's right that's right
and that's why they have to get they
have to get back
they have to get back but they can never
reach that first time
fix and you know i i tell my doctor i'm
honest with my doctor if i don't need a
pain i yeah i'm from western
pennsylvania i live in atlanta though
from western pennsylvania you know we
got pill billies everywhere uh
bill billy that's what the
pharmaceutical companies called them
you know i've never had a drug issue in
my entire life but like i've seen too
many there's too many people that i went
to school with that aren't alive today
uh and it's because they got hooked on
pills and then i i won't take you know
i'm aware i'm worried about pain pills
yeah and the problem is though is that
the government's answer to all this
is to tell people as soon as you get
into a program first off it's natural
you're gonna relapse that's just gonna
happen so accept it and secondly here
take some of these pills
to get you off of those pills
only program i'm telling you the only
program i have seen hands down
with any kind of success rate is those
who turn their life to christ i truly
there is no other i i've never found it
i've never seen you you've got to be
willing to accept you've got to be
willing to accept yourself
what you're you know being what you are
whenever you try to force people to get
rehab or you try to force them through
something they'll never do it you know i
i said
i'm a big believer in legalize
everything legalizing everything yeah
legalize that god no legalize all you
want
yeah the only reason why you can't
legalize everything is because everybody
doesn't have pers i everybody's not
built on personal responsibility so i
mean and
and you have a whole lot of immature
adults out there we see that more now
than ever
if you decide you want to legalize
everything you're putting
a lot of people
who aren't mature up here at risk now
because they don't know when to stop
well i believe legalize everything
because then you can then you can
regulate it make sure that it's clean so
you just don't have dirty overdoses and
then you can make it a public health
initiative
you can't sell no you won't be able to
sell it at a walmart i'm not not like
that so you know
you have dispensaries you have just like
you do with uh uh legalized marijuana in
states now they have dispensaries you
you have uh somebody looking over
because again most of these overdoses
are people just taking
bad like fentanyl fat dolls come through
the border they lace it in the drugs
that people are taking and then
unknowingly so is that all going to be
legal in your world
yeah yeah
personal responsibility
joe biden just made menthol cigarettes
illegal yes illegal yeah
that's an attack on the minority
by the way
wow just saying you can't drink out of a
plastic straw in california but you
think they're gonna they're gonna
legalize fentanyl woman was it with in
california had the metal straws
fell down it went in her eye and she
died
yes you can look that up
every democrat policy is literally
designed to kill somebody somewhere i
swear it is
that's so true i swear it everything you
got not you you yeah yeah
everything that democrats touch turn to
garbage and it's literally if you are of
the democrat party you've got to really
rethink what that and i'm not saying go
republican you've got to really rethink
what this party is doing
leah did you say menthol cigarettes are
now illegal joe biden's trying to get
them off the market correct he's trying
and i think he's winning you guys i
think he is winning the argument and
honestly
menthol cigarettes really really cause
it's horrible if you look into how
they're made what they're made what it
does everything about it yes they're
horrible they're worse than just regular
cigarettes and they were pushed on
black black community yes sir
absolutely i smoked for 16 years
and all my black friends they all smoke
menthol and you know a true smoker when
you're out of cigarettes and you've
never smoked menthol
you'll smoke one
and then you go find another pack oh it
was awful it's hard now think about this
think about what the government's
the black community is not vaccinated 70
in new york city they just told the
black community that you can't go into
restaurants and now they're taking away
their cigarettes
you know what else but yeah they're
going to keep voting democrat so oopsies
i was called yesterday
uh and i got a survey about the vaccine
uh and i during the survey i took it we
went over everything went over age they
were they actually they they confirmed
everyone in my household aged my
household who had it how many doses you
had and then they went into demographic
stuff age
um how much you make
uh and then race and after they asked my
race i said white
they act the next question was this is
this is an official government survey
the next question was is do you think
uh
as a white person do you believe your
medical coverage is better than other
ethnicities i was like what
[Laughter]
that was the very next question
which is just insane to me but that's
how they they try to market this stuff
down i
i don't know what you're supposed to
answer that question too any answer that
question is wrong right like there's no
correct answer that because you can't
judge
any other group based off of
it's the question when did you stop
beating your wife yeah
yeah it is yeah you know that's they're
looking at they're because they're they
i understand they want to try to address
an issue like leo was saying but yeah
you end up
targeting you know whatever you're
trying to address on you end up
targeting that community more so
with your attempt to help them you know
universal health care and universal
monthly income
that's what it's going to come to and
then we're not going to be able to get a
heart transplant for five years and
you'll die waiting for one
welcome
let me ask each and every one of you in
the comment section right now do you
feel your freedoms
are being taken away from you
how much how much do you feel that your
freedoms are being taken away
from you
mostly everybody is saying yes yes i
totally do yes
um
the reason why i say that is because
one of the beloved govern former
governors of california had something to
say about freedom
and not just to think about well my
freedom is being kind of disturbed here
no
screw your freedom because with freedom
comes obligations and uh and had
responsibilities we cannot just say i
have the right to the x y and z when you
affect other people
here here's here's arnold's dad arnold's
dad
arnold's dad was a member of hitler's
brown shirts to serve as first sergeant
there he is and he's talking about your
freedoms get out of here arnold and
you're welcome for letting you in
yeah austria's calling they want their
village idiot back uh
where where do freedom
i fight them where do freedoms come from
where do freedom where does freedom
where do freedoms come from
i'll pull him out of his they're just
you're born with your natural freedoms i
mean like you're you're look you're
speaking you're bored with everything
you're both people and nothing else
around you blocks them in like you're
putting a box outside of that yeah
you're supposed to be born
with natural freedoms but man takes
those freedoms away yeah i mean that you
know that's that's just how it is but go
ahead i'm sorry
but every society every society i think
i think our country is pretty good at it
i i i i i'm pretty good at what
sustaining our freedoms no no you mean
you can't have this conversation here
like we have in this country
uh we have a ton of freedoms that other
places just don't have
we're lucky that we are at this point
that we are not shut down by talking
about these things right we are kind of
we might uncle conversation until they
find out about it yeah i talked to my
uncle years ago and i said no no no we
can save this we can come back we can
come back and he's like brian you don't
understand i said no we're not over the
event horizon yet we're not there he's
like no brian you don't understand
we're in free fall we're already over
the event for horizon we're in free fall
you don't even know it i'm like
damn it fast forward five more years now
yes
it took me it took me a while
to agree with brian and leah
who had been mentioning this last year
woody they were telling me
that freedoms had were being taken away
and i was like there's no way american
americans won't let their freedom be
but over the last couple months you
start looking at how many people are not
engaged they don't want to participate
they don't want to save their freedoms
there are a few people that are online
that are saying like like i said earlier
who are saying uh they want to control
us well if you really sit back and look
at things they are controlling
everything that we do
i mean just just because they want us to
put on mass now sudden oh we need to
fight back but how about other controls
about the money that's being spent or
uh uh uh or
or the big corporations
that are siding with the woke americans
and we can't do anything we are being
controlled you know i i will agree that
apathy
is the enemy of freedom uh but i again i
i may be up maybe i'm just not there
that's why i don't see that yet i don't
i don't believe our freedoms are being
infringed upon
this is the new don't believe that
this is the new guild
this is the new gilded age
this will be coined the new gilded age
uh from the early uh early 1900s when
america was quoted as being apathetic
toward political uh foreign political uh
policies and we were called
isolationists
um yeah there's so much political apathy
right now uh foreign abroad uh people
are so complacent they've got their
money they've got their checks they've
got extra money
they don't want to be engaged in
politics because it's too difficult and
it looks awful and it's ugly it's
horrible i don't want to go to church
because now i got to change who i am
because i'm really
doing a lot of bad things i shouldn't be
doing uh so i'm just going to run away
from everything and just spend my money
ignore it all
that's what's going on right now there
there is a point there again there's a
little bit of that we do have
you know
entertainment
bail available to us 24 7. alcohol was
always wide open during the pandemic
yeah
uh yeah they made they made it easier to
access yeah yeah yeah
that's alcohol
not only that um doordash and all the
other people start bringing you yeah
they were delivering them yeah yeah they
were a lot of deliver uh containers i
know bars that weren't allowed to um
serve or sell to go drinks suddenly
everywhere turned into new orleans where
you get to go drink everywhere you went
to and just walk out with like your
slime how about dora something called
dora that they're pushing out nationwide
uh but it has to do with uh drink drinks
outdoor recreation area
cities are now opening up to where you
can walk the street here in my city you
can walk the streets and there's a sign
that says dora ends here
so you can't walk that to that side of
the street with alcohol
this is this is my libertarian
i'm okay with that i'm okay with that
but i think that people need to
understand moderation and be responsible
for the things they do yeah
as you go into
this weekend and i am able to keep my
stuff together entirely i'm not talking
about you i'm talking about the whole
damn city be careful let's see what
diseases out there that's where i get to
the people today
are not
personally responsible for well they
should be
no moral guard
for their actions anymore and
when you now if you give them that open
nymphs to do it
then you ain't closing pandora's box
because they'll fight you
too because then they'll say okay now
you're trying to take away
my freeze you see i i think it's
i think we have a mental health issue
the reason why we have issues with drugs
and alcohol and that's why you can't is
the mental health type
the thing for everybody if i mean if you
look like
if you got you know
look we got a whole lot of people that
are off the cliff right i mean if you
say that you can't just say
uh uh let's make everything legal yeah
because a lot of those people are going
to go nuts you know we got to figure out
ways like
they're going to go nuts anyhow though i
mean how's the war on i thought this
how's the war on drugs how did that work
out how did i think we're losing
no no you know what i mean like
prohibition government got rich
it's called china it's called china
it's called china you know how you win
the war on drugs
you you start a war with china you
outsource it yeah you outsource it yeah
you push the red button and then it goes
away
look i'll make the scene no liability
hey china why don't you
you know
no liability for us what's that's a
look at the um uh the vaping you know i
vape uh look at the vaping stuff that
happened you druggie it was
it was but it was linked it was linked
it was linked directly to um vapes
coming in illegally thc vapes coming in
with uh coming in from china from china
oh look at that it was from china
but they were coming from illegal where
they were coming through black market
networks they weren't in the legal
stores they weren't in the legal areas
where you could buy it illegally yeah it
was from the black so yeah it's
the same argument the same argument but
they talked about i know what you're
talking about woody because they started
mentioning in the news everywhere you
know a few people died here five people
died these kids died you had 10 people
die i mean people were dying you know
fives and tens and twenties yet
they'll never
report on a daily a yearly a monthly
basis that cigarettes are claiming the
lives of hundreds of thousands of people
or however
i mean nicotine is way more addictive
than
just about anything
south of heroin think about that in in
this day and age just think about this
in this day and age say that we never
heard of cigarettes ever before and
somebody just invented it today
and they went to the government
to legally sell it
will it kill anybody yeah probably will
is it addictive yeah i'm pretty damn
addicted we actually put more stuff in
it to really wreck you oh yeah all the
chemicals there is no way you could
start a cigarette company today
not today no unless you're in china so
why is it
hey listen have you guys ever heard of
something called sophistry do you know
what sofastream is because that's going
to be the ruin of us is that a drug team
no a service tree is the deliberate use
of a false argument with the intent to
trick someone or a false or untrue
argument an example of this is when you
use a fact in an argument to make your
point even though you know the point is
false oh that's called lion
yeah there was a woman i knew
it's called cnn and that's where your
fall will be when we talk about losing
our freedoms we're going to lose them
because of false arguments that they put
all this falsery in and it's not true
and they try to make it true that's how
you lose your freedoms cnn cnn gets on
there and cnn says
you won't get covet
if you get the vaccine
they create that argument that is what's
happening
that is separate from history
with truth
throw some truth out there the americans
are strong do what i want
americans that's called history when you
say what you want that's not true
america's committed self-destruction
china
manipulation
yeah americans come together like we
always do in the past we came together
for world war one you go along with we
came together the revolutionary war and
we came together for for for for rights
for for slaves to free this like us
americans were so good and now
it's time
to be good again to be great again get
your vaccine
like no you didn't
you lying dirty what's wrong with you
people flip your legs for anybody
everyone
wants to look it up it's called
sophiaism s-o-p-h-i-s-m if you want to
take a look at it it's again an argument
apparently corrected in a form but it's
actually invalid and that's what cnn is
doing it's an argument used to deceive
carolyn to um
to switch to switch to a little uh
somber
oh
man
yeah i'm gonna bring it up carolyn
carolyn says caroline sorry i haven't
been watching and i've been watching
mike lindell
uh
yeah off the stage
yeah um this was god love him this was
um
this was mike lindell a couple days ago
they attacked me
they buried it
you think about that
but they got something they want to show
you off stage okay i guess we have
something off stage but so we're live
streaming though
so you want to talk
i think we're going to i think we're set
up for a break and then maybe we're
going to talk a little bit right when we
get back there we're going to go in no
we're not going on a break put up that
movie again run the movie there's no
breaks we're streaming 72 hours live
streaming so around the world this never
stops you guys can go eat that's fine
but i ain't eating i'm staying up here
for 72 hours before they ruin our signal
ladies and gentlemen lunch is now
available in the back hallway thank you
yeah we're going to put the movie up
again if everybody missed it i want to
get the movie up tabulation system and
then we'll let's come back from the
movie
we're going to have dr frank street or
go he's going to get on there and do his
presentation
now uh mike glendale is doing this
symposium
uh trying to um show
uh what he believes was the cheat the
major cheat that happened across america
as of last night
dominion
uh was given the the goal
to
sue
uh sydney powell
rudy giuliani
and mike lindell for one point three or
one point 1.5 billion dollars each that
is each the judge
uh
and a whole lot of people are trying to
make something out of it but the judge
was a trump appointed
judge that gave the go-ahead for
dominion
to do that now when um lindell found out
republican counties are being won by
trump but by a much smaller number than
projected
and then you have philadelphia much
closer and able to do its thing because
rudy giuliani will tell you philadelphia
is the
kingpin of election fraud but it wasn't
possible without stuff like this
mike lindell walked off stage to get the
news
we don't know
i mean i haven't watched what has come
up i've you know come from that
since because i haven't been watching
this symposium but um
steve bannon came out against
he was four he's been for mike lindell
you know he's been supporting
banglandown but he also came out
uh against what the symposium
has been doing because he said
what lindell should have been doing is
putting the
the the
the the facts
out there immediately instead of running
that video over and over and over again
and
not
particularly speaking to the facts of
what happened
uh
and
you know he's saying is now this is
steve bannon
he's like this big big waste of time
basically
i mean that's steve bannon said uh again
i haven't watched it i haven't watched
it but um
i i don't know y'all i um
i guess you could say first uh for those
watching
um
it's a high bar
that that you must reach
to prove defamation
and when we're talking three four four
and a half billion dollars against
three people
dominion has got a high bar to to prove
their loss
their damage monetary damage i mean you
say i am damaged but you've got to prove
that
and you've got to prove that in a court
of law so i mean i i'm tongue-in-cheek
we were talking about this earlier
telling you i said well maybe maybe the
judge did it on purpose to expose
dominion
you know i don't know but it's possible
i mean look mike lindell is the only one
fighting for what he believes in i think
he's a good example of how more
conservative should be if they want to
fight for their cause you got to give
him credit for that
you have to again i i i think that
every election deserves to be free and
fair and to be
relooked at 100 percent thousand percent
you know
transparency transparency
for a free and fair election is pivotal
and you know
this is a good thing if you have
evidence and you're being sued it's not
a bad thing if you again if you have the
evidence i don't know that he does i i
didn't watch the symposium i you know
you know honestly i didn't watch it um
but if sydney powell and rudy giuliani
and
mike lindell have evidence a
a lawsuit's not a bad thing right i mean
kathy said are you down on mike lindell
um
i think
i think that i speak for
brian and leah as we've been speaking
about this since last year if you got
the evidence
don't elude to it
all i mean
i know what you have to do when you go
to court you have to you know
you have to put the evidence in front of
of the judge and whatnot
uh
that's something that the trump lawyers
didn't do
the trump lawyers didn't do it and the
trump lawyers got in trouble
because
all the cases were were thrown at and it
wasn't just because it was dim judges
it was because of dumb lawyers and i'm
gonna say it was dumb lawyers because
they didn't answer what they were
supposed to answer right
okay and that's why that happened it
wasn't because the dim lawyers were
cheating if
you if you have the right information
if you have the right evidence
you can't
you can't suppress clear evidence
unless it was obtained in a legal way
but
um with mike lindell
he's a good man
he's a good patriot he's a great
american i just don't want to see him
just destroyed
off of i'm because
i think leah said this earlier on
another show he believes
what he's saying
he's str he believes what he's saying
but
there are many times that a whole lot of
us believe what we're saying
and sometimes
sometimes it's not
true
well but when you when you break it down
i think maybe the the complaint that
maybe we all have is maybe that that and
it's easy to arm chair quarterback this
that maybe there's a different way of
going about this mike i mean i i'll be
the first one to jump in your camp and i
have been in your camp the whole time
along
and xavier said it in the chat
there ain't no way in hell
joe biden got 81 million votes i don't
care who knows it there is just
physically no possible way he garnered
81 million votes without a campaign
right he didn't campaign
it's worth looking at but i look at it
and go uh i look i look at it and i go
uh
you had one of the most polarized
elections in us history right you had no
idea
yeah that was hillary clinton bro this
was this was uncontested it was a joke
yeah nobody cared about joe they didn't
even know he'd make it alive he stayed
in his basement that's not polarizing
that's pathetic you don't think people
were again
people voted against donald trump
right
more people voted against donald trump
than voted for joe biden
that's what you that's what they want
you to know just like they told you that
it didn't come from a lab in china
that's what they want you to think the
problem was another entity went let's
give joey one million votes not
realizing the joke that obama only had
80. no i don't know obama had 60 60 the
highest vote getter ever was 67 million
by obama ever ever ever
trump crushed that
with his
70 some million and now all of a sudden
you're telling me
that joe
joe i don't know where the hell i am
out did barack obama's 08 run yeah
if if more people if more people vote
but then you can have that if you mean
if you if you get more mail-ins
easier to vote you make it easier to
vote more people vote i mean well well
i'm glad i'm glad that y'all brought up
the mailing list because i sat here in
fear
i don't know whether nobody believe i i
don't know nobody well some people might
believe me but i i sat here and every
time before we got get ready to go on
the show i was like
holy crap these numbers are going up
like i mean i've never seen them before
i was like there's another 20 million
that voted yesterday
what
i was like
it was almost to the point because i
don't think this country
i don't i don't in my lifetime i've
never seen this country
vote at least 50 or 60 percent
no not this country no 50 or 60 percent
of the population
no
i don't even think that many people are
registered but
the numbers were going
we looked like we were going to hit 50
percent of the country voting
between joe biden
and donald trump
right before election day before
right right right right and i was like
yo
it's something wrong
there is something wrong going on oh no
that's okay
whatever okay
look i'm telling you
i don't i didn't i didn't see it
but i know a lot of people it's
anecdotal evidence but i know a lot of
people
who would don't normally vote that voted
in this past election i know a lot of
people that are pretty apathetic when it
comes to voting to vote
i tell you what if you if if you know a
whole lot of 60 million people then fine
then i'll say he got 80 million votes
but if you're talking about um seven or
seven to ten
you still gotta question the 80 million
votes okay
a lot of people that had a reaction to
the vaccine
and i had a lot of people that also got
coveted after they got a vaccine and i
also know a lot of people that died with
the vaccine who had coveted i'll tell
you i'll take what you say woody woody
i'm gonna i'm gonna grant you what you
just said and i know it's anecdotal
however
i do know factual things that happened
on the republican ticket
scott presser signing up and training
hundreds of people
in the sign ups
for for signing up for registering to
vote for the very first time we're in
the tens of thousands
at the trump rallies tens of thousands
of people were there and they had
hundreds if not thousands of new
first-time voters
signing up for the first time at the
trump rally
million
extra
votes on top of 2016.
i got his ass off i got to say this
about
i got to say this about the extra vote
for
um trump too
because when you're trying to hide
something you got to cover yourself too
and
i'm not
no i am saying i'm
if you are adding votes to
joe you're going to you're going to have
to add some to the other guy to make it
look like it's reasonable okay
all right that's how that's what tells
me it was an outside the democrats
aren't smart enough to pull this off
this was another country that did this
right and they damn well know they did
it and the reason why the democrats
don't want you to investigate it is
because they just know that joe won they
don't know how he won because internal
polls showed that it was not good but
they won so they just want to keep
running with it and don't look don't ask
don't tell that's what the democrats are
doing but i'll tell you one thing that's
really strange that you can't explain
woody and you cannot explain it because
history shows that when ohio and florida
go red pennsylvania goes red too and it
didn't go red another weird thing was
house come the joe was voted on the
ticket but yet everything else was
republican isn't that weird that they
voted republican the whole way down the
ticket but they voted for joe on the top
you can't explain that one either only a
foreign entity that would not understand
our politics would do something like
that democrats aren't smart enough for
an entity did this and the democrats
don't want to ask him
that girl is preaching today or
they love the result
i love the result and by hook or by
crook we got it i said pop at the top of
the ticket look uh raphael warnock got
more votes in georgia than joe biden did
right people voted for him that didn't
vote for joe biden some people only vote
for president it does happen i i think
the government for joe and then voted
republican the rest of the ticket down
is what i'm telling doesn't work that
doesn't make sense no explain that
you're you're based then off of ballots
you've seen yes
that is that that is the truth they came
out on your favorite show maybe cnn
no you don't like seeing msnbc even
questions oh i don't watch that why is
it that they voted for joe and then the
rest of the tickets read that was the
question that they actually admitted and
said yeah that seems strange again i've
seen a lot of places where people didn't
vote for joe biden i said georgia people
didn't vote for joe biden that voted for
raphael warnock they didn't vote for
john either voted blue the whole way
down no they just voted for a single
candidate they decided not to vote for
democrats don't do that though that's
what i'm talking about i'm talking
democrats voted for joe and then voted
red doesn't make sense
who who'd you
think about it like this
you're going to vote warnock in
into the senate
but you're not going to vote joe bide
they didn't vote for
they they didn't vote for what they
usually they're down to is they didn't
vote for other people on the ballot they
went in and they voted for raphael
warnock
if you look raphael warnock ended up
with more votes than joe biden ended up
with
uh
that really proves my point that joe
biden probably didn't win
well
it's just who who else is the vote for
some people don't like
i don't if i don't like other candidates
i will i will vote for any one party on
a ticket i'll vote for independence i'll
vote for you know china attacked our
health and they checked our they
attacked our politics they attacked our
health they attacked our politics and
they also attacked our druggies um red
button
the only thing
it's not it's not um
well whatever um
i'm just saying
that
whatever
increased joe's numbers
also increased trumps
to to make it look close
where they could have blew it out of the
water
i'm not saying
again um
again
uh
81 to 70. 80 some million is 70
something million you're talking about a
160 million
votes 160 there's 333 million people in
this country it just makes sense it
doesn't make sense i mean
i wish
for uh people
right i wish that we had 70 of americans
voting okay i wish
that time is
maybe one day in history that time will
come i just don't think that it was in
2020. ladies generally we got to get
ready to go it is uh wow what a channel
yeah yeah we we we're
uh
we
all we thank everybody for being here
um today we brought um have had brian
back from his vacation we got woody that
um
um sat in for the week and did a great
job we got
bella with the funniest with the funny
um stuff and the blue eyes
funny stuff
not polarized pathetic yeah it's not
polarizing it's pathetic
that has to go into the hall of fame
there
we got to have a ball
yeah we got to have a hall of fame
fame of sans and let me tell you another
thing
so um
but ladies and gentlemen we want you to
visit my pillow over the weekend
mypillar.com
uh
as you notice there are a lot of people
that are on social media right now and
they're saying just go there use my code
and that's it
we have various things that we
that we have
in our homes we have these things and we
want you to have them too
and we have yeah there we go
uh we got the brochures we got we got
the sheets we got the mattress toppers
we got the slippers i'm wearing them
right now
i'm getting the pajamas the two yeah
yeah
right now is fit 50 off go there and get
your sheets today go there and get your
sheets today these sheets are not like
real regular sheets that you get from
walmart these are great sheets okay
uh they're 50 off of there and
i'm telling you
you are doing yourself a serious
disservice if you don't have a mattress
topper on your bed if you've if if your
bed is uh seven to ten years old
maybe even five to ten years old
you know you got a little action look
look we're all enough here
okay
we're all done
we're all adults here i mean
unless there's kids watching
well well you know
if you beat that mattress to death in
the way
craziness
then this mattress chopper is going to
work for you okay
it's a one-stop shop they roll it up and
it's it's vacuum sealed it shows up in a
square box at your house you open the
box you pull it out it's amazing once
you cut it open the plastic shrink wrap
it well make sure it's in the right
place because that thing really sounds
perverted
it opens up nice and neat and it starts
to come to life yeah that's good
beautiful mattress
yeah
leah's mine is in the gutter oh yeah it
is
that's great
that's great no but ladies and gentlemen
not only do you get the mattress chopper
you get it with two free pillows okay
you get it with two free pillows and and
just stick your pillows don't forget
this if you do get the pillows stick the
pillows in the the dryer okay
uh for about 20 minutes
put it on heat and um
yeah yeah
um
yeah my pillow my pillow
dot com you can use the code name wayne
we
back these products uh 100 we're back at
don't
also
don't forget
to
uh
cbdlion.com
forward slash wayne dupree 20 off on
your products use codename wayne again
at cbdline.com
forward slash wayne dupree use the
codename wayne for 20 off on your
products and
please don't forget
www.neverquitwater.com
uh the ceo or the owner was here uh a
couple of weeks ago he's gonna be back
in in a couple weeks to talk to you to
answer your questions but remember this
water
hooks up to your your faucet
in the kitchen in the bathroom wherever
you want to take it if if you go on a
trip and you go to a hotel you want to
take it there you can take it there
it gives you the best clean water that
you have ever had it also cleans your
food a whole lot better than regular
water
it has a hundred plus different uses and
you can get it for at least forty five
dollars a month or
zero percent
interest payment plans
and
you can buy it out right but yep
you can uh but you go to the website
www.neverquickwater.com
sign um add your name add your email and
uh he will get back to you he will the
owner uh will get to you immediately
it's it won't take him a long time he
will respond
write all your questions down give it to
him okay now and here's the thing i like
to jump into because i get excited about
this water um
your body a lot of viruses a lot of
bacterias a lot of cancers won't live in
an alkaline body
and this water is health water it is to
keep your body alkaline more alkaline so
that way you're not so acidic when
you're born into this world
you're alkaline
almost a hundred percent
wow so
get closer to how you were when you were
born alkaline more pure and you can do
it with this water if you haven't got
there yet and asked questions about it
what's wrong what's wrong do you not
care about yourself do you not care
about your family come on now step it up
that's the way to put water best way to
rehydrate yourself after working out
that mattress topper you know
[Laughter]
oh
oh my gosh all right y'all we gotta go
leah brian
woody wayne thank you for everybody
tuning in we hope that y'all have a
great weekend remember pray for us we
will be praying for you
keep keep keep god first um and also
love your families or
love whoever you got um
make sure yeah because you know some of
y'all might not be married and some of
y'all might just have a a special other
uh if
you want
yes if you go oh whoa yes you might have
a harem or something like that you know
concubine concubine whatever
um
either way
either way believe me i'm just i'm
wasting time because i'm looking for the
outro here so i'm trying to listen don't
forget hunter biden's art expo is this
weekend so don't go to it be safe
you know what that's um
what's what's the thing we said earlier
flip election no
no is it oh history
no that's not he's an idiot no that's
not a
something that's something
that's not a something that's a
something yeah you said it oh did i oh
oh
that's not
that's not a polarizing that's pathetic
[Music]
so
okay